turtles mutant karate teams I want to
know everything about you our dad is
definitely not a giant rat that makes me
feel like he's a rat hello everyone
welcome to the big ticket interview for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant
Mayhem I am Perry nemroth and I'm lucky
enough to be here with some of the team
behind the film hello guys thank you for
being here and congratulations on the
movie thank you for having us thank you
so I got a lot of very specific Turtles
questions I want to ask but I am a New
Yorker so top priority for me is pizza
I've got a couple of pizzas that they
eat in the 1980s animated series and I
want you to tell me if you would
actually eat this pizza first one feels
like the softball to me this is a
chocolate chip pizza who's eating it 100
yeah we got that that's right yeah let's
try a little Oreo one earlier yeah
earlier today we ate a lot of disgusting
pizzas legitimately like with noodles
and Sushi on it
actually yeah I feel like I could take
on any pizza
so you said you tried the chocolate chip
pizza was it chocolate chips or
chocolate chip cookies it was like Oreos
it was like Oreo crumble there was a
Snickers bar in one of them I remember
there was there's like bits of it it's
not good things
yeah yeah it was far enough to skip out
on that one
here's one little make your your stomach
turn more a marshmallow and pepperoni
pizza oh I think maybe I'll be like
Curious
you didn't see the bit but you were
describing some tame pizzas compared to
what we just did yeah
they do eat that on the show right they
do yeah all these they don't there's
some guy on YouTube also who made every
single pizza and tried them all and did
he like that one I think that one was
tolerable peanut butter and clam pizza
if you could do that please step away
from me
all right I'm glad we found the breaking
point that's not pizza anymore what was
the worst one you did wind up beating oh
probably the one with the sushi no I
thought that the noodles
itself
cheese popcorn yeah the licorice
licorice pizza there was one with the
Jelly instead of sausages
I like Dove really head first into that
one it was a mistake I could use our
haul interview to talk about pizza but
now I got to get into your movies I'll
throw my first question about that to
you so I'm a big turtles fan I will
watch replay anything this franchise
turns out but when you continue a series
like this you want to do so with purpose
so what was your break story moment on
this script that confirmed to you guys
we've got something and we should run
with it
um it was very much from the very
beginning our idea was to focus on the
teenage part of Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and to me I you know the first
movie I wrote was super bad like a high
school movie and I made a lot of high
school movies over the years and I've
always loved like teenage movies you
know and it was the one thing they never
did with Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
they always had like men in their 20s
and 30s doing weird teenage boy voices
and trying to like emulate teenagers and
and so that was really where it started
was like What if we really focus on kind
of the teenage desire to be accepted and
to be normal and this kind of like
coming of age story and and what if we
cast actual teenagers I like the sound
of that yeah so one of the things that I
love about this franchise is that the
more it grows and evolves the more
on-ramp opportunities it gives people so
everyone's got a different starting
point with when they became a Turtles
fan so for each of you can you tell me
the first Turtle thing you had or
experienced whether it was watching a
show having a particular toy you name it
me it was actually taking my kids to the
first movie
um and I I just thought it was a cool
concept and you know when I first heard
about the Ninja Turtles and the fact
that they do karate and live in the
sewer and they eat pizza I was like this
concept was pretty dope
animated movie I mean I was blown away
by you know the production and just how
real it looked and it's just the gift
that keeps on giving because like
everybody in my family a huge ninja
turtle fans love to hear it how about
for the four of you first Turtles thing
in your life
um when I was like I want to say like
hey I went to go see the Michael Bay
movie and I was a big fan after that I
was like this is cool like the music was
cool like the anime like the CG I was
sick I was like I'm a big fan now and I
had like Raphael's size and I remember I
used to like play fight with my friend
with a little size I used to think they
were like to use like to like as like
swords but they're actually used to like
defend which is
yeah for me I'd say it was um the 2012
television show I think that's the first
time I kind of got introduced to it and
then I would just get kind of like the
Legos I had like the turtle lanyard I
think I probably dressed up as a turtle
one year and from then like my left four
has just continued to grow and grow so
to be here it's just surreal
yeah um
I feel like me uh the turtles have been
like this monolith and culture for as
long as I've been alive and like way
before that and they've just always been
there so I would say my first Turtles
experience was like seeing the kids with
the lunch boxes at school and like
seeing the pajama pants and like
sleepovers like they've just always been
around but I myself have never doved
deep into it and I kind of want to wait
until after this movie has come out
because I feel like we were doing
something so new with like the teenage
perspective of it I almost thought like
well would it help if I saw what an
older actor did with the character or
not like I was like I'm probably not so
I just kind of this is my first foray
into the turtles Universe like
officially and we've been playing the
games and I know all about them but I've
just never gotten into them so this is
my introduction this is my ramp point
this is my ramp point right here
For Me Mine this minus the same as
Shimon that 2012 series on Nick really
uh really helped me and I just come home
from after school and they would just
always be on the TV so I mean it was
something that I've always gravitated
towards and just a franchise that I've
always enjoyed so to be part of it with
such an amazing cast is his dream come
true honestly so we can learn a little
bit about your version of the turtles I
got a two-parter for all four of you can
you give me your turtle's greatest
strength at the beginning of this movie
but then also I want their greatest
weakness the thing that will do them in
in their fight against Superfly if they
can't overcome it work as a team I think
for Raph at least I think I think his
greatest strength could be his temper
and and his his strength I feel like at
least in hand-to-hand combat but I think
it could also backfire on him and also
be the downfall of Raph because he might
get too hot-headed or or let let
something get to him too much to wear
that's a good character exactly his
strength
exactly
yes 100 I guess like with Leonardo his
thing is like at the beginning of the
movie he's very much like splinters so
like he loves all this Ninjutsu stuff he
loves the honor that his dad is
instilling into him but we see
throughout the movie he becomes this
person who wants to leave the sewers at
the beginning he's the one like guys
we're trying to be a crime-fighting team
but his like ambition to get out there
really comes when he meets April one
it's the first human the turtles
encounter and it's the first like on a
one chance that she didn't freak out and
leave like that's incredible what are
the chances of that so that like
friendliness that she displays it really
gets Leo to to be more acclimated to
escaping the sewers and and seeing who
he is outside of Splinter's watchful eye
and how he becomes a leader for his
brothers like away from the teachings of
his dad you know I guess that's it yeah
for Mikey I'd say his greatest strength
is how he's able to like improvising
with everything like go with the flow
kind of you know always aware of his
surroundings at times and you know if uh
if something's coming at him he's gonna
you know try to make something cool out
of it but I think that's also kind of
like one of his weaknesses too like not
really paying attention and being so
carefree and being not so you know with
the team like his brothers and
everything like that like not following
Leo's rules and he's like you know Leo's
like formation he's like no I'm a
do a backflip in Cartwheel into the
battle so yeah that's why Mikey was
always my favorite I love this Carefree
attitude because I don't I'm planned to
a tea yeah
um my character I feel like Donatello
his strength is is his intelligence and
it helps him out a lot because he he
plans every single move he makes but
also it kind of weakens him in the way
that he doesn't really know always how
to react he always has to think things
out and calculate and calculate things
but also just like like he relies on his
brothers and like as much as he may seem
like the smartest he wouldn't be as
successful as he is in fights or
whatever he's doing if he didn't have
his brothers to be by his side to
support him all right now of course we
gotta highlight Superfly here too I mean
it's a new character Superfly it's kind
of like an amalgamation and based off of
the Baxter Stockman character which is
in the movie also but
um it was a cool opportunity to I think
it's I like when these movies introduce
new villains but also have ones that I'm
hoping will be included as well and this
was like a great opportunity to yeah
kind of build off of the mythology of
the of the previous iterations there has
been like fly people throughout the
various versions of Ninja Turtles but
yeah the idea of the character uh and of
doing the character just it really kind
of brought it all together and
solidified things and was a was like a
very funny but also scary but also like
relatable and understandable
um but also like formidable villains so
it kind of uh like did a lot of things
that we like and it was a giant cool
looking fly monster yeah we just thought
looked cool honestly okay so that tears
up an idea I wanted to ask you about in
terms of his motivation so I know he's
all about wanting the mutants to take
over the world but I feel like with a
big grand plan like that there's usually
something personal lurking underneath so
what is motivating him on this Mission
from a personal perspective oh Superfly
you know he just want to be loved you
know he just want to be you know
accepted by you know all mutants of
course but you know humans too but he
realized you know at an early age
especially when they take out his Pops
that he's got to kill them all you know
all humans all two Footers gotta go you
know so so uh he builds up a little
resentment for people because of their
bad reaction to mutants these are all
sentences and explanations that I would
expect from a Ninja Turtles exactly yeah
I'm a children's film
you brought up his group of mutants and
I know we get a glimpse of them in the
trailer does anyone have a particular
favorite in that group oh Paul Rod is
Mondo Gecko and that was always one of
my favorite characters and he was not in
represented on screen that much but it
was always my favorite toy
um and the toys honestly had like so
much like thought put into how they were
designed like it's funny me and Jeff
both remembered like Mondo Gekko had
like a roller skate on his tail like and
the implication was like too heavy to
drag along behind him so he tied a
roller skate to it and and and and it's
funny he was like one of those things
that both like stuck in our heads and we
put it in the movie and uh and and Paul
Rudd is just so funny and I've known him
a long time but everyone all the mutants
are funny Hannibal Burris is a weird
frog creature and Rose Byrne is a giant
crocodile monster and Natasha dimitrios
a bat creature she only does bat
creatures uh it's uh yeah there's a
they're all so funny and John Cena uh
it's uh you know everyone's everyone so
great and we're lucky to get them all
all right I want to ask a little bit
about the voice acting experience here
Seth I'll start with you on that because
I know you were influenced by your
experience working on The Lion King in
terms of the actors actually being in
the booth and recording during their
sessions together which most animated
movies don't do so first can you give us
I guess the reasoning behind why that
isn't the typical way of voice acting
performances are captured and what
challenges you guys have to overcome in
order to make that work on this film
yeah uh I think they don't do it just
because it's way harder it's way harder
to schedule having everyone there at the
same time but it's technically much
harder to record it and I was just
telling these guys like yeah I've I've
been in like 20 of these animated movies
probably over the years and on almost
all of them I've never even met the
other people until the premiere you show
up and you meet them and you know the
type of Comedy I like is very like
naturalistic and reactive and loose and
and
um and and that always is elusive in
these types of movies and then I'm good
friends with John Favreau and I've known
him since I was young and he put me in
his Lion King movie and we recorded all
the stuff that was with me and Billy
Eichner and Donald Glover like together
we were actually together and it was so
like a live feeling that I like really
that stuck in my head and then when we
started to do this I was like we've got
to have them all together and and then
we did we did One recording when they
were all together and it was like fine
and it was very like scripted and a
little bit rigid and then I remember
like the recording studio we used has
this like tiny little like Booth like a
restaurant Booth where like and like all
four of them would like pack in there
and like eat snacks and just like say
insane things to one another and I
remember going and listening to them for
a minute and coming back into the
recording booth and being like that's
what we need to do like we should throw
out the script and just tell them what
the scene is and have them all just like
screaming each other and and and talk
amongst themselves and kind of like
bicker and banter and and and really try
to capture their real energy and then we
started to do that and then when we had
Cuba come in for Superfly we had him
actually there with them and they could
react off of him and and
um yeah and there were some sessions we
had like seven or eight people like
connected do recording at the same time
and it was amazing it's so awesome can
can each of you no spoilers of course
but can each of you give me an example
of a time you were doing a scene and
like stood there and said to yourself we
never could have nailed this unless we
were all in the same room acting off of
each other I I definitely have the
example I I don't think this is a
spoiler but I don't remember how it came
about but we were all just starting to
make fun of the stereotypical New Yorker
yeah pretty much yeah and it evolves
but it's like they were like yo ah can I
get a bacon egg and cheese and then like
Brady would add in like yo the hockey
way or something Shaman would add in
there and like it just turned into this
like Beast of a scene that came out of
nowhere and it's like I'm so excited
he's good in that way whenever I get a
bacon egg and cheese now I'm gonna make
it I'm
it's so unique that that Seth is I've
never worked on a project before
especially with like this many amazing
people and and uh like we're set to just
be like all right guys we'd come to the
studio and be like all right argue about
something related to tick tock and go
yeah and that's literally how obsessions
would go and it would turn into like
brotherly love and those arguments which
is which really helped so I mean it was
it was a lot of fun with anyone that
came in Superfly first meets the turtles
the banter that goes on the little extra
things that are said in there you
probably just wouldn't have if it was
just
you know me just doing the recording
them just doing it you wouldn't have
those little you know natural gems that
land when people are kind of you know
when they know what they need to say but
they act you know they're ready to rip
too you know so I just think it it made
it a more dense and realistic experience
than you know you can go to animated
movies and sometimes you could tell you
know the voices and how they come in
that it's not
you know kind of cohesive but with this
technique and and with this way you
couldn't get nothing but juicy yeah
scenes it was also like natural feeling
like always it just felt so like real
which was which was funny because the
scenes are like a giant fly talking to
four turtles so whatever you can do to
make that feel as real as possible is is
good I love hearing that he can't wrap
this interview without highlighting Jeff
I'm obsessed with Mitchell's versus the
machines now this movie looks incredible
I think he's one of the best of the best
out there in terms of directing Adam
can anyone tell me something about him
as an actor's director and leader on
this production that you appreciated and
you're excited for more actors to
experience in the future when they work
with him a more animated yeah I think I
say with Jeff it was like a thing of I
appreciated how comfortable he made us
feel at all times how open he was just
like Seth was to our improv and things
we were willing to add and how
collaborative you know he made it feel
and you know he was always so
high-spirited throughout the whole movie
and you know made us laugh and you know
share some dope moments throughout the
whole um filming of it so he's just an
amazing person yeah his creativity is so
strong like and he's his energy like if
I go to the booth and I'm
having a chill day he knows how to get
me going like he knows
like say to like get in this mood to
people to just say and improv whatever
line that makes sense for that specific
part of the scene yeah he's a
what I what I've realized you know in
working he just you can never do no
wrong you know it's like it was like it
was never where he was like uh that's
not working try it this way it was kind
of like give me more give me more give
me more give me more and you know I
worked on the animated film and and guy
was real technical he wanted you to get
every syllable right and it was just a
rigid way to work here you feel like I'm
gonna go in here for a couple hours and
have a bunch of fun say the craziest
stuff I can think of and he's gonna say
you did great we'll see you next time
they say the term big booty boy racism
[Laughter]
I'm gonna wind down with one last one
here because I hear the turtle's love of
movies is on display in this film so
let's say all these characters got
together and you know beep up and
Superfly they are invited to have a
movie marathon what movie would each
character pick to put on that lineup are
you crazy I'm watching Superfly
the original you know what I mean yeah
yeah I'm watching Superfly man you know
what I'm saying good movie holds up
really well yeah for sure Richard
Roundtree was he uh no no man this is
Ryan O'Neal
so we're starting starting with uh
Superfly who's got the next movie on the
list the fly okay
probably
are we talking about from real life or a
turtle's perspective whoa you take that
off whenever you're more passionate
about okay from a Mikey's perspective
he'd probably do like uh
probably be like a comedy special like
somebody's comedy special like fairs
like a Ferris Bueller or a Seth Rogen
movie
that's super bad I thought super bad in
there we were gonna have them watching
that in the movie but there was no clip
that we don't swear
yeah I feel like Donnie would watch Like
The Matrix or something because he's so
into technology like the futuristic
world he would definitely like he's
definitely a little nerd he's a little
geek watch like some sort of anime movie
I see uh I see Ralph watching like
Bloodsport or something oh yeah super
like super aggressive or like the
Terminator or something like that but I
feel like with Leo his thing is is it's
kind of like with the combat of Wrath
but more in like a um I don't know how
to describe it I feel like Leo's
favorite movie is Rudy exactly yeah
what's that like Friday Night Lights
what's that one Lucas from the 80s oh
yeah Lucas about the nerdy kitty likes
Bugs exactly yeah let's do that one
let's just throw out Lucas no I was
thinking John Wick dude I feel like he
would love the action scene
yeah up what's he picking you know
probably The Lion King because I also
play warthog in that movie which I
honestly didn't realize till I was like
a year into playing a warthog into this
movie and I'm like oh only warthogs for
me apparently
all fair I'll happily do this movie
marathon I have to let you all go I will
say huge congratulations on this movie
thanks for sharing some of your
experience with us to everybody out
there watching thank you so much for
watching this big ticket interview and
do not forget teenage mutant ninja
turtles mutant Mayhem tickets are on
sale on fandango.com right now